hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to seven days to die
with my good buddy wait how you doing
today I'm good how are you guys doing
yeah there we go you're asking them a
badami is that I asked you second last
week second exactly what the hell
obviously I am far more Barney than my
audience I'm not I'd be nothing without
you guys why they're leaving I love you
okay anyway so we had a rather
productive night didn't we're good or we
built the door a door I said pretty much
assuming the 90% of you actually watched
the nighttime stuff but anyway we built
the door that doesn't really mean much
for us but I'm also building through
other stuff also excuse me I don't
really have anything else new to build
in my thing though can you build um
hubcaps uh hubcap mind's eye I I don't
know I really don't how would you be
able to even do that but one of the
medals huh I don't even see anything
else in my eye my thing for like I'm
trying to look at this I've got uh I've
got I'm assuming some of the stuff like
hubcaps and whatnot the game's designed
to make you explore some I guess but I
mean I don't have enough stuff in my
inventory to make everything that I need
there's gotta be some components that
I'm missing that's not allowing me to do
what I need to do a brain sure wide just
because I am do think gooder than you do
not mean that you am smarter than my
butt so low low low low low low low
I was trying to make the low mean face I
don't know if I succeeded no no no
something like that yeah do your best
one
come on three hold off we're gonna do at
the same time okay
all right two one okay well if you think
that I'm better than Wade rate comment
and subscribe in the comments below
no we live in the comments sob don't
tell them what to do rate comment
favorite and subscribe and your other
favorite YouTube channel not this one
now wait but some random guy if you
think who's better get that number dial
now I'm Roger standing by we should give
out your phone number right now again
how about we down that be lovely call
1-800 markiplier oh no my phone number
no what if that was what if there was
I'll bet you somebody well I guess it
couldn't be markiplier but no no
complier something mark up wait em er ma
RK IPL that beaten me market fool markup
all good I'll 1-800 markable today okay
careful to get your daily dose of mark
Apple goodness no one can live without
markable it's your mark get your
remarkable - hey day Oh get your
markable - okay everyone wants the
market poll if you know what I mean okay
ah ow wow where'd you come from [ __ ] ah
ya gonna call me that any more what any
mohawk what any more what what are you
stuck in a loop wait have you is your
programming stop loop loop fruit loop I
don't know
no it's candy circles what oh yeah candy
circles my favorite and your favorite -
right Wade are your circles they're
candy they're candy and their circles
get yours today or tomorrow
hey wait hang on maybe a commitment I
can make buckshot and I can make
hey it's completely roofed in now yeah
hey I can make a pipe bomb a pipe bomb a
pipe Obama join you gel how do I make
that how do I make that that's always
breaking our door see let's say paper is
and buckshot yeah what amazed shotgun
shells oh I need paper that's the one
thing that we need we need a little
paper
I've killed way more zombies than you
did wait you probably have cuz I've been
building and I cook you dumb all to
death don't make me yeah you too
don't want you to kill come on AHA Kia
I'm gonna Hawk you're good
don't make me this is where this
survival team falls apart
let's go shuck each other okay why would
you do that you you said you're gonna
look me wasn't really gonna why would
you be you are Keo I'm inside the house
that's good what did that start when do
we get the spawn inside the house I
don't know all right
don't you dare I'll Chuck me again now
got a resource my inventory all over
again
due to actually because I put all my
stuff away to pick up your stuff yeah no
wait a minute I don't your pickaxe oh
okay give me my pickaxe oh I see only
this stuff that wasn't in there
whoa Jesus you okay over there good haha
that took me like two seconds to
recognize what you said it was like dude
I'm like what what excuse me okay anyway
what do we do now
collect this venison well yeah but
besides that we got a lot of venison get
the farm going
I don't Oh cuz I have the pur taters I
didn't you know I'm I have this funny
feeling
Oh yuck Oh yuck that we can't grow in
this biome what I got it I just have
this funny
feeling no you see how you look around
and nothing's growing oh no I'm just
saying like no I'm just saying that it's
just you know a possibility I am NOT I
haven't exactly been reading the
comments so I don't know if people have
been telling us that we can grow
existence of comments on every one of
your videos
no I'm serious here look look do you see
anything alive us I was just dead you
killed me
well you came back the material well
yeah but whatever but I mean are you
luckily and evil now I'm do how you
swinging that shovel there Wade how you
uh you you've been shoveling long time
open shovel look funny what whoa whoa
wait is that how I shovel I think that's
my shovel but I'm gonna make another one
just because this is true I had one no
this is too funny for me oh my got if
that's how you really shovel the whole
time hang up I gotta get rid of some ah
what do I get rid of feathers get rid of
feathers okay
now tell me if I'm shoveling normal is
that normal do it again no wait what am
i holding the shovel backwards and
upside down no you don't throw that
alright that's what you're doing hahaha
where you going oh you hear kill another
deer doggy oh you killed it
yeah well like the wolf hungry like uh
thirsty like the coyote I really like
the desert uh so uh I'm just thinking we
should probably abandon this house
they're really not growing on
I spent so much work I don't know how
it's normally smote down but watch watch
watch I don't know how you spend work
but that's what I did watch way just
please watch it's gonna break your heart
to pieces okay so I got them up I only
have one potato see ya oh you have to
till the dirt oh oh well don't explain a
lot and we probably need to have water
in here too
probably how do we make a garden hoe uh
don't know oh don't worry I made it I
made it shut your face I made it I need
to get till the garden bury the body
once you me pardon me you want to say
that again till the garden bury the body
Hill the garden Mary Avari okay watch
this OOP it looks planning okay it
worked
oh Jesus they're easy over I think we do
need water soon though yeah we need to
make a bucket and go find a water source
uh well good luck finding that here can
we make our jars of water can we put
them down I don't think so huh baby I
know you can make a bucket with iron
ingots okay no you only drink the water
that's right
okay bucket don't see bucket in my thing
it shouldn't be in your thing I'm not
making no bucket let me try do you have
iron ingots I got nine of them
okay good luck that's it up for a bucket
that should be enough for a but it
helped but it didn't fully boil it it's
a bucket of boy bucket o'fun oh this is
why we are the number one comedy team on
YouTube watch out everyone
you are no we're not but we can tell
ourselves that oh if you think that were
the number one comment team on YouTube
please go away because obviously of some
lapse in judgment I'm just I'm sorry I'm
thick we need 7 forging metals to make a
book weight forging metals yep forge
metals I just looked up the recipe
wait okay okay I turned all my iron into
fortune metal we turned all the diamonds
at the port I had a flashback I sure
heard all of our diamonds at the pork
chop house a great moment here anybody
else remember that rape our girls
okay I got a bucket I'm gonna go get
some water you know where a river is no
but I got a map that's true there's a
river dude down the way cuz I live in a
van down by the it's dark never my you
know here it's dark remind okay so thank
you all so much for watching we are
making progress as you can see if we
could just stop [ __ ] around for two
seconds I don't think that's gonna
happen but we can always hold go thank
you all so much for watching thank you
wait for being here you're welcome
as always we'll see you in the next
video
obstacle shut up your ass
I'm gonna go on a night run their house
they broke through our door they broke
through the metal door and it turned
into two scrap metal oh I'm gonna go
make a run for some water did we blow up
there if we blow up just a little bit
alright I'm gonna go run for some water
you stay and protect the house Hey
okay ah I just lost it I lost my [ __ ]
isn't it you lost your shiz net did is
that like Skynet you styli through my
mouth and through my shotgun and really
what would you do that because I
overreacted are you dead oh good
don't be dead stay alive if preferable I
can't believe I said those words but
stay alive you really care I don't I'm
just having your baby baby baby oh good
good your triple baby water got a bucket
of water bucket of water is fun look at
the water coming at you from a million
miles above the space station of Mars
yeah threw on his electric skateboard
car needed be new I need a burning a
feel like I'm still thirsty all this
running oh look I got a bucket of water
I should purse elfin a nice succulent
beverage I should drink this bucket of
water no I'm gonna drink it
you fool I didn't drink it I was gonna
drink it but then I was like no
markiplier does not do that markiplier
is better than that were compar does not
drink four buckets no except that one
time when I drank a bucket of protein
powder from ah why did you block up the
front door you [ __ ] let me in burski
how about you let me in working on it
thank you
do not ask me ah but your problem now
and wash up I got water but I don't
think I made it in time for this potato
I picked up pop oh that's so cool I
picked up the potato and it still made a
swirl
hello this water looks kind of funny oh
I just killed that potato why got it and
I got it
I lied again I'm a habitual liar
why's the water just floating there do
you mean just floating there just
thought not feeling why are you still
talking like that I don't I know you
don't know are you okay
this body needs to evaporate is block it
up for whole body nice your door hole
some by the door hole bothering you
there Wade yeah yeah Oh looking poor
forgot present for you evaporated there
you go see the gun 35 dirt oh boy I
don't care I'm gonna leave that to
disappear
no don't disappear for that their garden
I've got too much stuff I need to get
rid of it
buckshot coal gunpowder forging metal
I'm keeping that just wrote a song right
there do it again good book shot lump of
coal - seam nitrate guy I said it wrong
I said oh you're probably that site
again gunpowder forging man lumber coal
buckshot is that it that's much better
than powder for Gmail lumber coal
buckshot alum powder for team a lump of
coffee but she'll only record metal
bumper call box yell up gold board
metals good to go books yeah I didn't
realize I was such a wear my headphones
like a headband now because of head
banging lump coal Boca yeah my name's
yeah I'm a women now
od nama fema nama goobie gaba we but you
know something need a lovin need a
loving away i can't see now i look like
that guy that cyclops from x-men Cyclops
what you mean cyclops as I said psych up
from ik that guy X Cyclops from x-men
you mean Cyclops
yeah the X cyborg claw I got it look at
all the PO
wait check this out see this potato it's
ready to pick but it is already picot it
stays in there awesome sure than there
oh I trampled this crop ah my bad I
didn't mean to wait not only do we cook
potatoes just eat them raw rubber what
it's ready to pick so many taters I
think I think housing taters ball
come on against your taters get him your
taters off my Tatas ok get your taters
on my Tatas
gotta eat him up all up I'm putting them
up doing up like you're a stripper yeah
what he does
you know potato seeds don't actually
exist I just put the potatoes in the
ground and they you know how if you
leave potatoes alone they start tweetly
out of a spud yeah they just bud and
yeah why would you get in here look how
they all they got in over here somehow
where did that guy come in I don't know
huh
there's a loan that whole fortune made a
buck shy old male book shout all right I
think it's time to close up shop but
let's leave him with a little bit of
song look how fast this grows
are you ready lady Oh ready to sing
Oh potato potato oh we love you Stowe
potato potato we love to see you grow
potato potato
you want to make me murder potato potato
I'm gonna kill you dead run wait run
Wade run away from me the potatoes
potatoes make me see you die run and I
know where do you go please you're just
gave me I'm gonna kill you oh hey